well the problem with atheism
politically starts with the phrase I've
advised people who are themselves
non-believers not usual atheist as a
harshness to it it is it is a
repudiation now I'm not necessarily a
minimum me but it comes across as a
repudiation of religion and religion is
very important to many people which is a
source of good feelings for many of them
it's not always unfortunately a motive
for good behavior I've noted that in in
the international situation religion it
said me more often a cause for people to
shoot each other than do than to help
each other when you get splits within
two countries or even within countries
where it's Catholics versus cousins Jews
versus Muslims Buddhists versus Muslims
as it has been in in my and maar Hindus
vs. Muslims there's a very sad extent of
that but religion is important to people
it has a history of being seen as a
source of good behavior Americans
history has given the majority a greater
goal than in some other places and from
the polity instant point the questions
white white why pick a fight that
doesn't have to be waged I never
expressed the fact that I was not a
believer in any in any theistic approach
because it was never relevant I did
fight very hard throughout my 40 years
in like an office to prevent rules and
laws that put non-believers at a
disadvantage I've fought very hard
against the establishment of religion
against people being forced to subscribe
to religious views to get certain
benefits etc but beyond that it didn't
come up in my own case there was another
reason why I didn't talk about it I'm
Jewish obviously there was a strong
terrible history of persecution of Jews
Judaism is a religion but it is also an
ethnicity and for many of us who were
Jewish America today
the ethnicity more than or even to the
exclusion of the religion that
identifies this but for me to have when
I was a public official obviously first
Jewish person to be elected to the
Congress in the United States since 1884
it would have looked as if I was or to
some people it could have been distorted
to be a kind of I'm separating myself
from the Jews and I wouldn't want to do
that even today secular as I am when the
High Holy Days of Yom Kippur Rosh
Hashanah come up I am NOT gonna be seen
in public doing things that other Jews
won't do for religious reasons I don't
observe them myself in a religious way
but I would not want my behavior to be
used to embarrass or or discomfort
anybody who does religiously follow them